all right check check one two1 1212
welcome in people to Harry Potter and
the Half Blood Prince part two if you
guys are watching this later on the VOD
thank you so much for being here a
couple of notes Here uh at the beginning
of the stream we always like to do a
little bit of a just chatting so I do
have time stamps I'll put those in
they'll be below so if you want to hang
around for the just chatting portion
that's great if not you should be able
to skip right ahead to the game another
thing about the game though as we found
out last time there's a lot of
copyrighted
songs and basically what happens
is YouTube will flag all of the songs
that have been copyrighted and over 4
hours of game playay I mean there were
probably 10 of these so I can keep my
video up but I don't make any money off
of it all the ad Revenue goes to the
people who uh own the copyrights for
those songs so YouTube gives you a
couple of options you can completely
mute them you can try to put music over
them you can try to just remove the
music my point being there's a lot of
different options so if you're watching
this later on the VOD and any of the
audio sounds distorted or off that's
what's going on but um my apologies for
that uh that's unfortunately just just
part of streaming on YouTube is you have
to to get around the copyright issues
but we do stream this live and when
we're going live everything sounds
normal you get to hear all the music and
yeah so that's what we're going to do
here at the beginning guys welcome in
welcome
in welcome back to another Tuesday
stream do I see warri land a Wario with
the tier one membership Wario welcome in
dude thanks so much for that membership
we got Dylan in the house as well we've
got Anna here anna welcome back Anna
always good to see you lonus Blom lonus
Bloom I guess it's lonus Blum lonus
welcome in thank you for being
[Music]
here jumping toad stool here in the
house as well
Metatron good morning guys good morning
or good afternoon depending on where
you're at in the world I don't know
how's everybody doing
today
yeah man it was a kind of a disaster
well not a disaster but the uh the
copyright there were just there were so
many
so yeah that's one of the unfortunate
unfortunate side effects I guess but we
we'll deal with it we'll get around it
Dylan welcome in dude with the tier one
membership and that is 18 months for
Dylan Dylan thank you so much dude
always good to see you here
Wario yes I saw that dude you are a
member now it was like the very first
thing that popped up all the way at the
top of my little chat box here
appreciate it dude welcome in yeah guys
if you're a member here on the channel
that's also a great way to support
whenever we
uh because whenever you go live you can
have ads on YouTube has recently added a
lot of options for when you're live
streaming and so you guys may see some
ads today but it had like three settings
it would let me turn them on low medium
or high I'm like who's going to turn
them like when you read the description
for high it's like frequently interrupts
viewer experience I'm like why is this
an option so anyway we put it on low and
you guys may see them at different times
so hopefully it won't be too many but
then if if it is too many there's like a
whole different set of options that we
could try as well so yeah just aot lot
of uh copyright things we have to have
to navigate here on YouTube but yeah man
I uh enjoyed part one of Half Blood
prints if you guys missed part one we do
have that up it is up on the channel um
there may be some weird audio Distortion
audio going in and out with the music
because of what we talked about at the
beginning but it is up on the channel
you can go and view that and I enjoyed
it way more than I was expecting to way
more we are playing the PS3 version that
was a question we got asked a lot last
time the PS3 version on a PlayStation 3
slim no no emulation here of any
kind we are all locked in on the actual
uh Hardware here
today Devin welcome in Devin appreciate
it Sarah gifting out five memberships yo
let's go Sarah thank you so much for
gifting out those five looks like Devin
got one of them right there
Chris got one Arvin got one flattest
coyote got one and then Mark got
one how are you Sarah thank you so much
for gifting out those memberships now we
have five new members of house rack and
tour oh that's the other thing I was
going to say if you guys are our Channel
member you get access to all of our
emotes which I am in the process of
updating because now that this channel
now that we know a little bit more about
what the direction this channel is going
to be I think that's going to really oh
man it's kind of blocked out by the chat
oh
well oh well you can still see the alert
we just got the chat there too I've been
seeing a lot of streamers do this
recently I kind of like this what do you
guys think like when you're doing the
just chatting I don't like it as much
when you're in the game I want to keep
that as clean as possible but yeah you
guys get access to the emotes you guys
get access to the members only polls
that we do here on the Community page
and and also the members only videos
that we post from time uh usually try to
do once a month on those which we just
did one last week or so week and a half
ago so there is an update and that one
is kind of like a direction of the
channel what we're going to be focusing
on for uh at least the first 3 months of
2024 and so far it is going very well
we've had a lot of Wizarding World News
to discuss if you guys didn't catch our
video yesterday that felt like a lot
more than five did we get another set of
gifted
no I don't okay it just felt like way
more than five just hearing Nick in my
head over and over and over again oh man
too
funny Cheyenne so excited got up early
to make sure you didn't miss this hey I
appreciate it I appreciate it Jenny good
morning welcome in good to see you so it
seems like like the alerts they're all
they're all working right now as
intended I tested them again last night
cuz I I I knew we had some weird issues
last
time but um yeah it looks like they're
working guys if you're here uh make sure
you hit that like button before we dive
into the game if you're just joining
into the stream now you're still in the
just chatting portion we haven't missed
anything I like to chop it up with you
guys here in the chat for a bit catch up
with everybody see what's going on in
your world in your lives and catch up on
the Wizarding World News we do this for
about 20 20 minutes or so and then we'll
dive into some gameplay here of Harry
Potter and the Half Blood Prince Let's
see who else do we have in here I saw a
couple of other names pop up glad to
catch a live stream for once we'll be
lurking mostly C still at work hey all
good Sarah appreciate your support and
Sarah sporting that onee membership
badge along with Jenny along with
Dylan Murphy asan very
close I think that's the six Monon badge
but yeah now that we updated the
logo I've got to I've got got to come up
with some new
Badges and Dylan I think Dylan is our
longest what would you call it longest
tenard it doesn't sound right but he's
been a member for the longest I believe
has the longest
streak and I think the next one I can do
Dylan I don't think I can I think it
goes from 12 months to 24 months which
you're I mean I think you said you're at
eight was it 16 17 18 you're somewhere
in there
right Murphy aan nice to have the live
streams back magically got a membership
gifted during the live stream without
without watching that's crazy I don't
know how that works I don't know how
YouTube does the the gifteds I would I
would assume that it prioritizes the
people in the live stream but then maybe
it goes to people who watched
recently that's cool though that's cool
yeah I'm trying to bring back the live
streams though Murphy want to do them
once a week and and try to just play a
little bit of a a Wizarding World game
each week but right now I know I feel
like that nighttime slot works better
for I shouldn't say most people but I
know there's a lot of people who also
want us to do the night streams but I
got to be honest with you guys the the
the morning streams are just so much for
my schedule it just flows so much
better because by the time parents you
guys know you guys know like when you're
doing the the music's a little loud let
me turn it
down got the Hogwarts Legacy music going
in the background here but parents you
you already know man like when you've
got the kids in
school that
time like you've got the time when
they're in school then you pick them up
then it's like just a frantic Rush of
any kind of after school activities if
you're doing sports if you're doing
Academic Teams if you're doing track
what whatever it may be right you got
that little phase then you got to get
dinner in there
somewhere and then by the time dinner's
over it's like well it's almost time for
bath and bedtime reading getting ready
for
bed and so by the time my wife and I are
done with all of that which sometimes
it's just me because she's she works
12-hour shifts but by the time you're
done with all that I'm just like and now
stream I wouldn't be able to bring my
full energy I'm not saying the night
streams will never come back but for me
right now th this time slot is uh is is
working the best so appreciate you guys
who are here and I know for our our
people over in the UK and other parts of
the world that this this time really
does work a lot better so but yeah
jumping toad stol for me looks like
Dylan already answered you there but
yeah I'm on Eastern time
so just a little bit not quite 10:00
a.m. just
yet like a good chat before jumping into
the game hey me too jumping toad stool I
mean I kind of see it as a way to dude
why is the this webcam man I'm going to
have to like see if there was some sort
of
update yeah it has this thing called
tracking this is kind of cool watch
this it's crazy
right oh see now you're seeing my cable
my cable management
I strategically look at that look at
that I strategically hide that so it's
not visible on screen but yeah it's
supposed to be locked into one
place but uh this webcam it supports
like these gestures like I think this is
one is that zoom
in it didn't do anything but I saw the
camera flash oh wait it turned it
off hold up hold up guys hold up maybe
okay it turn dude that's it okay so
that's called
tracking so I just turned it on so let's
see now it should follow me around yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right all right now
now we're going to turn tracking back
off with the hand gesture okay so it
should be off now oh my gosh that I've
had this webcam for years well not years
but maybe like a year and a half or so
and still clearly am am not using it to
its full
capability okay gesture settings off I
don't even want the gestures on okay
wait actually I do want to show the chat
this real quick apparently we can do an
L to zoom
in come on oh wait it it it's trying
it's thinking about
it it's flashing okay I think it's I
think we've confused it now V is
something called
whiteboard
yeah it kind of zoomed out there I'm
just turning it off man I'm just I'm
just going to turn it off right now
before we mess anything up further and
then I'm going to hit this little uh
position one right here to get us locked
into where we want to be and then I'm
just going to just going to close it out
and hope that it stays Christian gamer
welcome in good to see you good to see
you jumping toad sto 2:30 in the
afternoon for you
I know Jenny it's a nice it's a good
start to the morning especially this
this more like kind of
peaceful ambient Vibe we got
going lonus you know the crest in the
clock tower that you tried to take in
part one if I remember correctly it's
much easier than you tried to do o which
one you talking about the one where I
had had to uh the one where we had to
run down the hall and jump and and try
to hit them is that the one you're
talking about Jake welcome in dude
welcome
in oh that's right Wario I did see that
the uh the trailer was releasing today I
mean what they'd shown so
far I'm I'm I'm cautious I'm very
cautiously optimistic getting closer to
like the hype territory if the trailer
today delivers then I will probably be
on the hype
train H what is that H Julia I know
that's someone else hold on wait is that
house I think that's house I think
that's house in the
house I'm trying to remember who that
was they told us last time and I'm
getting the names on Twitch vers over
here confused but welcome in good to see
you Joseph good morning my friend good
good
morning yes Anna see Anna
I Anna
Anna's a very positive happy presentence
in all of our streams and if we do night
streams guys Anna usually can't make it
it's a very sad time without Anna there
so I think about you Anna I do I do I
think about you not being able to make
it if we move them to uh tonight
streams trying to plan anything after a
kid's bedtime you never was
right oh it's tough dude it's
tough sometimes I'll I I will like
sometimes my wife's just super tired and
she'll go straight to bed so then I'm
like well I can play games or I can work
on stuff for the channel or play games
working on stuff for the
channel that's usually a pretty good one
so morning Jared says morning streams
for the win Jared welcome back good to
see you
man
love the morning Cheyenne says love the
morning streams nice way to start the
day yeah I mean I like because I'm if we
end around sometime in the
afternoon I I don't know it like gives
me energy for the rest of the day I'm
like man that was a great stream now I'm
ready to work on this for the channel
work on that for the
channel yes thank you Jenny smash that
like button
add your middle finger to the L
formation with your hand yeah ju I just
want to give it a nice like thick make
sure it's able to read it nice and easy
Dylan no that wasn't house wait who is H
Julia walmar that's it yes yes yes
walmar I knew it was somebody that I
uh a name that I
recognized and there is speaking of
house there is house in the house glean
the aspect love the music I know they
they did such a great job with the with
the music and
Legacy and fortunately they're very nice
about
not I'm going to I'm going to start
minimizing our use of the word c o p y r
i g HT I don't want to awaken the
auto bots on
YouTube cuz I was talking to
um oh I think he changed former L known
as Hogwarts Legacy explained I think he
changed his name to Retro Wizardry
now but he was reaching out to me on on
uh Twitter he said he has never had any
problems with this game on YouTube I
think he's got all of them up on his
channel and he said that this one he's
never gotten any copyright issues with
so I don't know dang it I said it again
see now we got to do just chatting for
another five minutes at least I don't
want to awaken the we need to come up
with a name for it what do we call them
like the inquisitorial Squad ooh the
YouTube inquisitorial
Squad we don't want to alert them so I'm
going to minimize my use of that
word we'll just call it YouTube and
inquisitorial Squad I think that works
but yeah Hogwarts Legacy man they've
always been very
uh very cool with that in uh letting us
use the I mean even like
the oh what was uh when they put out
that
big what was the name of that video that
music video that they
did why can I not think of the name of
it Overture to the
unwritten that whole thing we could we
could uh react to and listen to on
stream Sarah you like the morning
streams as a European your only chance
to get yeah see that's the thing if we
do the night streams that rules out a
lot of the uh European crowd Anthony's
galactic games welcome in good
morning sprs any interest in the new
Jurassic Park game maybe I remember
seeing that trailer I was kind of
intrigued by it
yeah concern for Avatar is keeping the
same comedic moments from the animation
oh like if they try to do the exact same
things again instead of just sticking
more to the spirit of
[Music]
it in the clock tower you have a bell
and on a Legge yes lonus dude yeah feel
free to share cuz I don't think I ever
got that one did
I I don't think we ever got that
one AJ draws welcome
in good morning AJ good
morning our favorite resident Wizarding
World artist shout out to AJ draws
everybody the Bots are always the the
the the YouTube inquisitorial Squad is
is always listening Anna it's very true
I mean like the second I ended that
stream last week you guys it it wasn't
long at all before they popped
in the detection
tool it would all be easier if the game
just had a music off but honestly the
music's so good and it's kind of a way
to reward the people here hanging out
live you guys get to hear it in it's in
its original intended
[Music]
form on top of the clock tower on a
wooden beam yeah yeah yeah that one yeah
I remember that one Christian gamer next
game I'm looking forward to coming this
year I really I I'm looking forward to
rise of the Ronin black myth Wukong I'll
play both of those and I want to play
the new Prince of Persia game probably
uh do that on the trophy Channel or
something which we haven't we don't
really talk about a lot but if you guys
enjoy platinum trophy hunts and like
like watching me go after Platinum
trophies I've done a couple on the main
Channel we did them for both Lego Harry
Potter games if you enjoy that content
we do have another channel that I'm I've
got a couple videos on now but I'm
really going to start putting out a lot
more on that channel in the
uh in the coming months let me actually
get let me get the link for you
here CU I had to change
my handle for
recently yeah here it is I'm just going
to post it in the
chat but only if you're like only if
you're into those types of videos like
if you're like nah retro that's on my
thing I follow you for the Wizarding
World stuff totally cool dude no no
issue at all but if you want to see me
play more variety other games like like
Christian Gamers asking about there
that's probably where we're going to
play play more of those things going
forward
no way we can win Guardian
Leviosa Dementors that's a good one
too the YT the YT yeah we abbreviate it
even further the YT guys they're on to
us they're on to us
man speaking of being on to us I think
it's time I think it's time let me fire
up the
PS3 plug in the controller oh no it's
flashing means the battery's low here
charge up for a bit charge up for a bit
while I chat to the folks here for
another
moment still owe you a guide for setting
up oh no rush Wario no rush but yeah I'm
glad to see you join the Discord
exclamation point Discord guys in the
chat for any of you who are interested
in continuing the conversation there
after the live stream ends but yeah
Wario I saw you joined up once we finish
this game I'm definitely going to do
Deathly Hallows one Deathly Hallows 2
two immediately after this as difficult
as it may be to make it through I'm
definitely going to do those two and
then after that I think I'll kind of
reset and figure out where we want to go
next
because I've never played the PS1
version of philosophers I've never
played the PS2 version of chamber we own
all of these now by the way I've never
played any of the handheld versions that
one we'd have to figure out some sort of
emulator setup I'm guessing to get those
where we could stream
them but um I've never played any of the
of the of the handheld ones at all like
the DS versions The GBA versions never
played any of those and heard some real
good things about them and then the one
you're talking about Wario the uh the
Chamber of Secrets on PC which I know I
would
enjoy I for sure know I would enjoy that
one and then prisoner of aavan on PC as
well I think that would be another one
that I'd be interested in checking
out
let's see who did I miss there Dragon's
Dogma 2 I never played the first one but
if I ever have time for it I'm pretty
sure I would like
it okay hold on what did Lina say you
can win guardi
it what I thought we tried that
man I thought we tried
that all right guys th those of you who
were here for the early part of the
stream thank you so much we're getting
ready to shift into phase two and some
actual gameplay let me actually note
down the time that we're shifting over
it's going to make it much easier for me
to do the time stamp
later
25 all right let's do this right
here there we
go all trophy information has been
synced excellent excellent
excellent no haven't heard about that
part lonus good morning elen welcome
in ever win the World Cup in in in
quatal cup we won the house cup I never
I never won the World Cup I was kind of
like okay I've I've seen I've seen
enough of what the game has to offer
dude look at all these all these old
icons
it cracks me up seeing all the I don't
even think these work anymore on the
PS3 Target it correctly first and then
you'll get it ah okay okay
okay half BL prints on PSP or DS maybe
even Deathly Hallows on
DS yeah I'd like to try and play all the
ones that
were at least have like somewhat of a
significant difference which is why I
want to play those early ones
again all right let me uh I got to
switch over my
monitor so I can actually see the game
in front of
[Music]
me hey Daniel welcome in thank you for
subscribing to the
channel welcome in also law James is
here we've got meor in the house
all right here we go guys Harry Potter
and the Half Blood
Prince and I'm going to mark this for
26 come on come on wake up wake up it's
trying it's thinking it's working really
hard come on you got this there we
go
all right guys welcome back to Harry
Potter and the Half Blood prins this is
part two and just for those of you who
maybe weren't here at the beginning or
who weren't here last time uh when
you're watching this live when you're
hanging out with us at the live stream
you'll be able to hear everything normal
as intended but on the replay the VOD it
will stay up on YouTube so you can go
back and watch uh however as we found
out last time a lot of this music is
copyrighted so if you have any point
where the audio sounds off or distorted
um or it's just completely muted that's
what's going on don't think your
computer is messing up it's just uh I
had to mute it in order to keep the
video um monetized on YouTube all right
so we actually played quite a bit last
time and got pretty far into the game
which I've heard is is kind of short at
least in terms of the
[Music]
story all right and one other thing I'm
going to do this
time see we got 62 out of did that just
say
1,680 on
[Music]
the the mini
Crest that's insane dude hey dbdh
welcome in yes we got the Weasley swe
another lesson Harry when you see
Dumbledore don't say anything about
Maloy he's up to something around even
ditched crab and [__] yes I admit that is
out of character but you don't have
evidence that he's doing anything if
he's not then why is he sneaking around
the seventh floor and the seventh floor
that's it he's using the room of
requirement that's why he keeps
disappearing off the Marauder's Map well
if he is using the room he won't be able
to see what he's doing in there that's
why we used it for da meetings
concentrate on your lesson with
Dumbledore he's waiting for you in his
office
okay so I think we they did show us that
last time but yeah like the music right
now
probably it's probably going to be the
first example you know what one thing we
could do I could turn it down a little
bit
more that didn't work hold
[Music]
on Warrior gifting out of membership
looks like law James got that membership
becoming a member of House rack and tour
Wario thank you so much for gifting that
membership LW James congratulations
welcome to house rack and tour you just
got access to our emotes here also our
members only Community polls our members
only videos as well right here on
YouTube the music is so loud why is it
so hold
on no matter what I do it still sounds
super loud to me
[Music]
all right I'm just going to turn this
down a little bit right here for you
guys and then I'm going to turn it down
a little bit right here for
me yeah that it it you are correct uh
Wario you are
correct I don't know why I feel like
that's something that they could add in
the future for sure can you help please
Nick all right so we need to go and talk
with
Dumbledore Professor D waiting oh my
gosh dude this being an older game every
time it does something like that it kind
of freaks me out for a little
[Music]
bit is that cadugan look at that there
he is I don't think I noticed that at
all last
time all right so I've heard there's
unlimited not unlimited but there's more
mini crests than we need for the trophy
so I don't think I need to go as
crazy on trying to hit every single one
of
those
morning there's a couple more of them
[Music]
yeah hopefully it won't be too many ads
guys I'm I'm trying out a new a new
setting today for the live stream we
talked about it a little bit at the
beginning if you missed it
but um YouTube's recently added a lot of
ad settings that are kind of confusing
on live streams so it's basically low
medium or high so I put it on on low
because that's kind of another way that
we
can sort of balance out the fact that
this is going to get I know this is
going to get hit by the the YouTube
inquisitorial Squad the moment we put it
up which means I won't earn anything
from it but if we earn at least a little
bit on the live streams that that helps
out a bit for
sure like when we're actually live if
that makes sense cuz I mean it gets hi
Harry are you here to see professor The
Dumbledore I am too are you all right
come on what's the matter it's silly a
Slither and stole my gobstone it's a
noisy hitter my mom got me for Christmas
who was
it
him wait here I'll get your gobstone
back Batman like Superman PC oh I think
you were talking to somebody else but if
you're asking me this this is the uh the
PS3 version here ask the Slytherin stud
student to return the
gobstone oh my goodness man so this is
where Hogwarts Legacy got the idea
collecting gobstones wait where is the
Slytherin is this the Slytherin that we
need to talk to hey did you take a noisy
hitter from the girl over there what's
it got to do with you give it back what
are you going to do jinx me I'm sure
Professor snake would love to know
you've been jinxing Slytherin he might
even give you detention super fire oh
jeez a Point Blank Range
Stupify are you kidding me
dude hold
on oh man wait what was Pego down
righto there we go nice Pego back at
[Music]
you oh my gosh I forgot what was what
was expell
armis oh jeez jeez this this this dude
is is Wrecking
me chotic spell armis
man lonus Bloom thank you for
subscribing to the
[Music]
channel oh this is bad I don't think
we've lost the duel yet I can't start
losing
now I can't remember what it
was there it is Dylan yes thank you dude
thank you
we only have like
three oh we actually did hit him with
that nice nice get close get
[Music]
close come on come on come on there we
go there we
go Harry you need accuracy my
friend oh my gosh Harry if you lose like
this there we go there now hand over
that noisy hit gos all over you and next
time think twice before you bully
someone hey let's go Harry you tell him
you tell him give the noisy hitter back
to the Girl by dior's
office oh man it still says that my my
controller is low I really don't want to
keep it plugged in the whole time I
think we're
good PS3 controllers man they had so
their battery life was
insane here you
are thanks Harry you're the
best thank you DB dvdh I appreciate it
yeah that's what oh that's what I was uh
I was going to say like that at least if
I have them Professor about Malo and
Dumbledore speak snake Professor snake
good de I trust sers my answer has not
changed no new troph to the business at
hand I have not been able to find many
memories of Tom Riddle at hoods I did
however find this one good the time off
you go boys the strange Avery don't
forget your
[Music]
essays look Shar there Tom
no Tom I don't know anything about H
cruxes and I wouldn't tell you if I did
now get out of
here I don't understand what happened
Professor slor has tampered with his
memory Harry I asked you to get to know
Professor slug horn now I want you to
persuade him to divulge his true memory
any way you can that memory is
everything but I believe you have quit
it practice you'll find your way there
more easily now the orders have opened
more of the castle good day
Harry lus it probably did this is not
the original
cable this cable went to like my uh
managed what did this one go to it was
like an SD card reader or a DVD
Professor M know what she want no but
she's waiting for you in the
Transfiguration Courtyard sounded
important
all right now mgal needs to see me so we
just had another memory with Dumbledore
right
[Music]
there we really should absolutely yeah
yeah yeah I agree guys that that's one
I've identified in my videos too that
the show could delve into more than the
movies Didion and I are looking for
Professor mcgonagal ah Professor
mcgonagal is in the Transfiguration
Courtyard at the moment
you should make your way
there all right Nick lead the way dude
you really should go and see M he's not
going to lead the way father and system
they're just like you should know this
you you just all you got to do is follow
Hermione sorry Hermione I didn't know
you were going to show us the way
actually be be helpful
[Music]
here oh yeah we can do like
this full-on Sprint
[Music]
[Applause]
dang oh
man come on Hermione
go Harry I've been do to search I went
to the library I checked in the
Restricted Section and I couldn't find
anything on this Half Blood Prince
there's nothing to say who this person
is good then they can't be that bad we
really
should she was rather insistent man I
need to reread this book
we really should go and see mogal she
was rather insistent because that was
like a really big I mean they were
really really trying to figure out who
it was weren't they okay wait we got
incendio now
too I'm pretty sure we learned
incendio yeah we did okay that means we
can access all of these now
incendio and we need to go to the clock
tower too house with the 499 Super Chat
house thank you so much dude appreciate
that hope this helps with the stream
love the committed direction would love
to see you play the handheld HP games
house in the house dude I uh I don't
know if you were here when we were
talking about that but yeah we were um I
think it would be really really cool
especially since I've never played them
oh wait do we have another situation
right here but house seriously man thank
you so much for the support it it means
a lot guys it really does
all right so we got another one of these
situations here where are you going
har come on
Hermione oh
[Music]
yes more little mini
crests yeah I do uh have a larger cable
somewhere
jinny and dealing with the the niffler
Emoji emotes whatever you call
them yeah that's I think that's the
perfect use for those get superat talk
to you after the unfortunate events at
the borrow over Christmas why is it
always you when something happens
believe me she's blaming us myself that
for years I heard you've joined the
dueling Club Harry I think you should
follow his example and the Weasley too
you can't be too prepared don't limit
yourself to your friends in Gryffindor
mind ah here's the person we were
waiting for I thought she said it was
urgent Alanis here is captain of the
Ravenclaw dueling Club you come along
with me Miss Granger and we'll sign you
up with Gryffindor dueling club would
you like to practice casting Levy corpus
with us I've always wanted to learn that
spell
okay bro Hermione was like
mcle says it's
Merchant all she wanted to do was get us
to join some dueling
Club it's not urgent thanks for teaching
us that lady Maloy thank you for
subscribing welcome and future Jewels
let's try a proper Jewel while you're
here ravenclaw's junior Champion against
Harry Potter Harry
Potter uh which one do you mean about
the you asked about the cat Castle
design you talking about in this
[Applause]
[Music]
game o Lev Corpus is kind of
fast there we
go I saw something from Dylan about like
firing oh my gosh that is the trick
right there firing it in like three
round bursts like that like just one 2 3
1 2 3 oh there's a Crest right there
[Music]
too
whoa oh you are done my
friend wait was that the the Ravenclaw
Champion okay another round all right I
was about to say come on dude Ravenclaw
Champion that's all you
got maybe it's just a tip from Dylan
we're just op now oh look look at him
doing a little Dodge there on the L
Corpus okay all
[Music]
[Applause]
right yeah look at that one two three
and they all
hit did this guy even hit me I don't
think he's hit me
once Junior Champion okay so they're
we're we're working our way up
to the top dog it seems wi well
done or duing clubs all around
Hogwarts potions Club Greenhouse potions
club and the green houses and quidd Club
that's pretty cool potterhead Mando
welcome in Lev Corpus one of the Spells
Snape invented yeah so this is the year
that Harry learned it wait when did he
learn L Corpus guys as a special members
privilege you can use that portrait
short
wasn't it the password is light against
Darkness why don't you try our jeweling
challenge just go to the notice board
when you're ready to give it a
go lady Malfoy good to have you here
welcome in training session I am rather
hoping Gryffindor will win the quiddit
Cup this year get yourself along there
Potter great quiddit teams are not built
on tardiness gotcha mle gotcha I mean
this game they really do I feel like
they they
took what people said about uh order the
phoenix like the
negatives and they try to make this one
a little more
streamlined like you you never have to
wonder about where you're going in this
one that's for sure I mean you always
have a clear next objective so it
doesn't feel quite as open but for me I
don't know man it just it it's just
working a lot better maybe because Order
of the Phoenix literally the only
missions were go find this
burst that was all you
did all right so we need to find
something to throw at that Crest over
there Lev Corpus this year from the
potion book all right that's what I was
thinking the reason I said year five is
because didn't he did we know it in in
the Order of the Phoenix game
[Music]
this could
work movement controls are so
[Music]
strange all right now let's kind of line
it up oh there was one right there of
course there
[Music]
was yeah see if they would just let let
you if they would just let you like aim
in right
here but then when I Let
Go it does that all right hold on let's
move let's move kind of right
here line it up
there all right back up maybe back
[Music]
up oh my goodness this one's going to
get
this one's going to be annoying I can
already
[Music]
tell Luna cassa in the Order of Phoenix
movie I forgot about
that there we
go yeah yeah I knew like in the books he
he learns
it from snate from the potion
[Music]
book I completely forgotten about the
Luna using it in order of the Phoenix
but now I can I can hear her saying it
in my
head come on AIM at aim at
[Music]
this all right so now we can go through
this portrait right
[Music]
here yeah Warrior maybe I would have
felt different if I actually
if I enjoyed the quest that they gave
you but they I just I just did not enjoy
them at
all light against Darkness har come on
pass friend I must change that
[Music]
password movie flub something the show
can the TV show can fix all right
somebody was saying
uh Hey portrait Pro
nice I didn't know if that one was going
to be difficult to get or not so that
means we've used all the portraits now
[Music]
excellent hey Virgil welcome to the
stream my
[Music]
friend to get to the grand staircase
when you're ready called them to the oh
you were talking about the portrait that
we just got potterhead Mando
right just want to make sure I saw a lot
of people talking about Crest make sure
we didn't miss a a Crest that somebody
was
mentioning all right got
you why didn't I enjoy those quests most
of them more fun to you I mean they were
just like all like fetch
quests that's how I felt about them
anyway are you there Nick she like hey
go get this for
me take it to this person go get that
for me take it to this
person whereas this game I mean there's
a lot more
variety all right through here boiled
gate shortcut what yes just don't tell
them
that oh all the way back down eh too far
gone now oh
wait hold on are we close to
the too far gone now Dylan we're going
to have to go to get the platinum trophy
I'm sure we're going to have to do a big
like Crest
run to finish everything out I'm
guessing that's going to be the final
trophy that we'll have to get is
collecting all the
[Music]
crests because I feel like most of the
other stuff maybe the potions one I saw
somebody I totally saw your comment
where is everyone they're already out
practicing great can you help me with
some Seeker
[Music]
practice I told totally saw someone's
comment earlier and forgot to respond to
it about for one of the potions trophies
you have to brew a potion in under 35
seconds which I think is not there's
another postage trophy that you get for
like finishing it within like 10 seconds
or less or something on the
clock which is the one that we were
going for last time St through the ring
you can real right I definitely feel
like it is faster this time
or maybe it's just they're giving us
tighter turns to up the difficulty a
bit here it
comes go
[Music]
on
who
[Applause]
I can't
believe I thought you had to you were
supposed to dodge those guys that's
hilarious you guys are like no you want
to hit them gives you more
time it's just like the positioning of
them like that they're usually right in
your path on the way to the the star
so you would think they want you to
avoid these but
no I do feel like it's slows you
down am I
crazy oh we're getting close
come on grab it
Harry Nice there we
go are the trophies pretty easy M store
yeah so far they've been popping pretty
quick personally I think we need a
better defense the other teams have got
really good keepers we hav that luxury
Ron's doing better than you could mlag
just offering some friendly advice one
to another well take your advice out of
our training room you're not on the team
mclen off the top rope with that
one
sheesh oh is you about the the potion
line nice thank you dude I've looked
find anything on H crupes go I've been
thinking maybe if you make a really good
potion in today's lesson it will put
professor slor in a good mood then he
might tell you what he's hiding from
Dumbledore yeah yeah that's not about
bad
idea is it almost time for Felix lookag
he makes gr look like a gentleman I'll
see you in potions hey Granger Granger
so is she see mcag well they went to
slug Horn's Christmas party together but
it didn't go well yeah come on let's go
after let's go to
potions follow Ron to
potions yeah even if we don't get the
potions trophy Feast thankfully with the
potions
club we should be able to get those at
any
time cuz I don't think anything is
actually
[Music]
missable yeah it would be nice to knock
the crests out before end game but I
don't expect it to happen I expect that
to be the last one that we'll need hello
Potter I'm a member of the finest
jeweling Club in Hogwarts Slytherin
we've noticed that you're quite the
jewelist I therefore permit you to
challenge me to a jewel uh no thanks
we're on our way to potions I'm not
asking you potty I'm telling you
supery the bullying in this game
[Music]
man right one
oh it's op man firing it like
that Lev Corpus is not working right now
for some
[Music]
reason come
on there he
[Music]
goes got
him H I didn't really try anyway come
along to our jeweling club in the paav
courtyard for a real challenge
considering such bad losers come on
let's got to I wasn't actually
trying the classic
yeah you could charge potterhead but I'm
just like is do you I don't know with d
with Dylan's tip I don't know if it's
worth it worth the wait
time you can just fire them not quite as
rapid fire as I was trying to do just
not spamming
it little like three round burst right
there it seems to work pretty
well organic trash welcome in Arvin
welcome back back good to see you used
to play this game when you were younger
it's organic it's actually my first time
ever playing this one it's one of the
ones that I never played as a kid oh run
up to a banner press oh we got this
again I think I also saw Mrs rakor in
the house everybody say hello to Mrs
rakor it is actually Mrs rakor if
anybody was
wondering the CEST behind the gate you
can't open in the gate so it's another a
three-part solution
really all right I thought I saw
something else right
here what is
that well would you look at
that 68 out of
150 not even halfway there yet
man Jamie good afternoon welcome Anna
this is your favorite
one that's right I do remember you
saying that last time got another Crest
right there and then Warrior was saying
something about
a only optional
spell all mini games have
clubs oh yeah I saw that
part then something about the uh the
optional optional
spell Alex watching from
France let's go man see that is the best
thing about doing the earlier streams is
that we we can capture more uh give you
guys in the worldwide audience a chance
to watch whereas when we do
our evening streams it's kind of just
the US
folks Transfiguration Courtyard hold on
hold on Ron we found two crests just
back to back right there let's see if we
can find another one here nearby
[Music]
oh wait wait yep dude it's like I just I
could sense there was another one
nearby oh come
on well come on
then I think the most annoying mechanic
so far is is having to throw those and
knock those down actually like I should
say I like the uh I like the mechanic
it's just the aiming if they would let
you actually aim it's kind of just like
you're you're hoping and
praying spray and
prey let's see if we can get this one
right here and just get closer to
it I wonder if it was any easier on the
Wii version may have been hard hard on
the Wii
version oh dude there's that that
portrait right there I forgot that
lady's name but that's
like it's like one of the well-known
portraits all
right oh come on
dude I think we're going to have to go
back up the steps again it was getting
much closer when we were up
there
mad skman BRB I don't think I said hello
to you m skitman there we go nice but
welcome in appreciate you stopping by
and hanging out all right that takes us
to
70 oh Alex that's that's an easy pick
for me that's that's definitely a
Hogwart pacy
too what do you guys think chat if you
had a choice between you could only pick
one
I already know how this is going to go
but I'll
ask HBO Harry Potter remake or Hogwarts
Legacy
2 I think the more the more difficult
question would
be like excuse me Harry Potter
spin-off or Hogwarts Legacy 2 or Harry
Potter MMO or hog or like a
[Music]
to
all right Ron I think I'm ready now
although I've enjoyed collecting these
crests right here we're almost to the
halfway point on Crest just need five
[Music]
more wait another Banner one isn't this
dude all these corridors look the same
didn't we already get this one maybe
not oh come on Harry you got to show
them your hops come on Harry you got to
show them there you
go there you
go dude we totally already got why did
you show me that again why did The
Prompt appear
[Music]
again stop it stop Flying round come
back down here Harry you've got to get
rid of her Harry I thought you were
going out with her yeah I am but please
just tell her I flew into a wall and
quitted or
something talk to Lavender I love
it yeah of course you would say that Mrs
rakor not the biggest
gamer M stor more excited for Harry
Potter remake in really M store I'm
surprised
a Voldemort spin-off right that would be
pretty crazy a hagri
spin-off what's the matter someone
something to my and the stupid things
won't stop flying around come down right
have you tried anything other than
shouting at them like wardian Leviosa no
I wish one one was here he'd do
something have you seen him come on I
don't lavender was dumb cast windian
Leos on your bag I can try and catch the
B she was just a bit smitten you
know she just loved her one one all
right C wi guardium Leviosa on
lavender's bag why are they doing
this you got
one get in the back you
Books Okay this is kind of
hilarious I love this as a as a little
Mission
here is there one more there it
is come on you thank you are you sure
you're not team Ron uh yeah I have he
was in the Divination Tower why would he
go there he doesn't do divination
anymore he said he wanted to ask
something important about his future it
must be about that's true Warrior not
like my one one so much he's always
thinking about
us oh you saw you saw uh are you ready
for potions one one back it
in follow Ronda
potions you saw a a Crest Linus behind
the banner over the door great mate
another trophy unlocked let's go behind
the banner over the door let see that
was probably back a little bit though
wasn't
it which honestly I'm sure we're going
to have to do a whole big honestly that
might be its own stream Crest
collecting it's just my guess I mean you
guys who have the platinum trophy you
might be able to O good
call let's see I don't think we can that
one's one we got a knock
down you guys who have the Platinum
could probably speak to
what the hardest trophy is going to
be you have more Health in dueling now
all right all right all
right Crest collector number
nine there must be a awful lot of Crest
collector trophies cuz we're only at
what was that 71 and there's 150 of
them I guess I should keep hitting these
two since we're going to need it
I agree Anna this game is
[Music]
hilarious all right come on get in here
all right let's see if we can do the 35
second one yo Dylan with the five gifted
memberships any suggestions Dylan
appreciate it dude thank you very much a
very complex welcome to five new members
of house tour I'll be quiet for a minute
so you guys can hear any
suggestions yeah you could do that or
you could just shove a bizor down the
victim's throat yes yes a bizor would
certainly do the trick excellent my boy
excellent a good potion maker always
knows how to counteract the potions they
are making which brings us to the task
at hand Brewing an Elixir to induce
euphoria can induce excessive singing
and nose tweaking if you don't put
enough peppermint
in I'll just restart this here in a
second I want to can I pause it here oh
we can nice Dylan thank you so much dude
appreciate you gifting out the five
there looks like we had Dave Mia got one
of those gifted memberships Louise
Cheyenne and dark sloth got those gifted
memberships from Dylan that means you
guys have access to all of our emotes
now you also can uh check out some of
our
community community not Community only
what is it members only videos that we
have on YouTube and also you get access
to uh the members only polls that we run
from time to time and you get a special
role in the Discord as
well appreciate it Dylan are we getting
double is it it's doing it's doing me
again isn't it yeah it's going to go
through them all see I thought it felt
like more last time no wait it just
ended okay all
right I don't know man sometimes the
alerts they have a mind of their own
sometimes they have a mind of their
own oh man Jacob and nude in the movies
didn't care for the oh the F yeah you
guys were talking about fantastic Beast
yeah it's kind of a mixed bag wasn't it
some good some
bad I think every Jacob was pretty good
though
yeah
all right so there's a trophy apparently
for doing a potion within 35 seconds I
don't think it's going to be this one
but Elixir to induce Euphoria all
right oh my gosh I think you should can
I restart slug clear that smoke my
boy the clearing of the smoke mechanic
is the one that just doesn't look right
to me I'm just going to let the time
expire I I want to start
over I want to start over that's also
why we moved the webcam if you guys are
wondering keep those in part one of the
stream the webcam was over there where
the number was so you guys couldn't see
the
countdown it is time to assess our
work it's always going to be blocking
something can induce excessive singing
and nose tweaking if you don't put
enough peppermint in all right here we
go I'm locked in this time you guys I'm
locked
in man it's quick on that one
shrivel
[Music]
F dude you really have to focus up for
these you really have to be locked in
and
focused it's got the potions up okay we
got to heat them
now no no no no stop don't
stop that's it right there it's so weird
to me when you have like back to back
heating like why can't I just keep
heating
it you have to progress to the next
stage though all right and then we've
got oh no where are these
things right here nope right there I
think that's it one
we
missed oh my gosh missed no nodding off
from the
job why are these so hard to drop
in got to watch The Shadow
[Music]
huh all right more stirring more
stirring porcupine Quil
I hope that's
this there we
go
wait yeah I know it gives you a time
boost for you but like it just doesn't
make
[Music]
sense terms of heating a cauldron no no
no no no no wormwood dude we got lucky
right there I'm surprised it didn't wait
is this wormwood okay and we got to
shake it up
first wait what
no
no it's gone it is Wake wakey okay it's
back all right and now until it's steady
okay I think this is the wrong
thing this is the wrong thing isn't
it it's definitely the wrong
thing isn't that quite Hur Hur time oh
now we got to shake it again
man please what dude what is going on
room
har okay good not pretty but it worked
we got there sir you knew Tom Riddle
didn't you Mr riddle had many teachers
whilst here at Hogwarts I know sir you
must get fed up of questions about
Voldemort and hore cruxes I'd ask you
not to talk about this subject but sir
Dumbledore put you up to this didn't he
didn't he I just want to know about
sends him
away go and meet Ron
outside slug Horn's like nah dude nah
not having
it all
right go ahead and get these little mini
crests while we're
here dark sloth thank you for
subscribing welcome
to the channel appreciate
it the pacing I know right has to be has
to still be bubbling when you pour it in
oh God and you just need a tiny tiny bit
is there a way to tell if you're going
to need a lot or a little is there like
a little indicator that I'm missing cuz
yeah you're right sometimes I start
pouring and it's just like instantly
changes color I need a good marking
potions I had to soften slug horn up so
I could ask about vold
yeah well I'm going to get something to
eat whereas other times mcgonagal wants
to see you in the astronomy Tower so why
would he send someone slitherin I'm not
your personal messenger don't ask her
yourself but the aura shut the astronomy
Tower then they've obviously reopened it
haven't they I SAR I am up to mle wants
to see
[Music]
you
mischief
yeah I mean you really don't have a lot
for non- dueling in this
game imagine if you
could just wing guardium it right over
the
top come on out like there's enough room
there Harry just just lift it on
up just just lift it
up that should work
right wait a second okay hopefully we
can repair it but wait now can we
like dude that's actually kind of crazy
I thought you meant repair I thought you
meant break the
gate I didn't know you meant to actually
break the
crest
what dude
that I was not expecting
that that's hilarious imagine if you
broke it and then you're just locked out
you can never get
it that's pretty
cool all right now now I can look back
at the chat some things I would like to
figure out on my
[Music]
own like locations of things I'm like
sure tell me but puzzles I definitely
love figuring out the puzzles on my own
like there's one right behind
us here we
go
I'm not sure what's going to be worse if
we end at like
146 and then we have no idea where the
final four
are that could be tough man that could
be tough I did like I always like to
whenever I know I'm going to go for a
platinum trophy I'll read the trophy
guide on a website usually like power
pyx or PlayStation trophies I think
it's.org or something
and they did recommend like when you
start collecting Crest try and keep
track of the ones you have like
seriously
150 you want me to just note down every
[Music]
time you know what would be clutch if
the actors in the movie do cameos I
that's that's been teased I know I think
there's a couple of actors who would be
on board for
it there's a there's a rumor I haven't
heard anything directly from Tom Felton
but there's a rumor that he would love
to
play Lucius Maloy which would be kind of
cool but it's still early they don't
even have like the showrunner yet so all
those rumors of casting it's all just
just purely rumors at this
point Yahoo we are on PS3 my friend
PlayStation 3 hard copy no emulation or
anything going
on all right Wario I see you I see you
you want me to go to the Courtyard to
learn the last dueling
spell let's see how do we get back out
there that's the
question I think this is actually
leading me
outside so how does the day night cycle
work in this game is it just constantly
going and then it resets when you hit
various story points that's kind of kind
of
cool yeah I feel like Tom loves loves
the world and being part of it so much
that I agree Anna I think he'd be down
for
anything all right is this the the right
Courtyard everybody's gone man it's so
quiet
quiet it's so quiet right
now yo this is
crazy Great Hall is the Gryffindor
dueling Club oh you said I need the
Slytherin dueling Club
huh
wait
wait did I pass
it
paved why doesn't it say it then Wario
I'm I don't like this hello hurry oh
yeah I bet I haven't unlocked it
yet that's probably why it's not
there Luna's coming to visit no she she
wanted out that
time have the auras reopened the
astronomy Tower I believe they have yes
all right let's just go ahead and do the
next Story part and see if it will
uh if it will pop up then
you didn't join the club you're only
invited oh so I have to go there to
start
it I have to go to the paved Courtyard
to start it is that what you guys are
saying Sir
Nicholas boy Beatles they're watching us
they're all watching
us oh yeah we need to go to the clock
tower too at some point now that we know
how to get that
one that Crest
there they're watching
us they're all watching us that portra
that portrait cracks me up every time
I know his his voice was way better in
order the Phoenix I
agree he sounded way more uh like
panicked all right time for the full-on
Sprint let's go
Nick which I think Nick reset I think
Nick is taking us to our next uh Story
Mission now which is fine we'll get the
we'll get the spell here
shortly it unlocks when you get there
nice thank you potterhead yeah so we'll
do that after
this playing Hogwarts Legacy as you
watch let's
go so what are you what are you doing in
Hogwarts Legacy Jaden are you like is
this like a replay are you still are you
just
exploring there's another of those
crests oh wait for real Nick
where you mean like a big one or did you
just mean the little
one there's another of those crests he
says maybe it's behind
here let's go dude Nick with the assist
appreciate it
man shout out to our boy
Nick
wait this way there we
go it's like your eighth play through no
way oh yeah you should definitely go for
the Platinum absolutely it's a fun
Platinum so what do you still need which
one do you lack for the Platinum still
have yet to get 100% you just like
that's interesting so you didn't want to
just go the 100% play through the first
time you wanted to like experience it on
on other houses and and stuff
first what do you want poter um there he
is [__] free view oh too late you're
the [__] who's turned up to see someone
who's not even here Mal voice sent that
message we knew that we knew that you
get him you get him oh D okay all right
all right you guys aren't playing
around let
oh my gosh
bro they got the big time combos right
there
fortunately we've got the
strats we've got the
strats there we go come
on see now she wants back
in you guys heard
[Music]
her
she can never make up her
[Music]
mind good night Sir thanks for playing
let me try come on then poter come on
then poter
poter we're going get
[Music]
you I do love the destruction like I I
know there's not a lot of it but the
destruction on the furniture stuff's
pretty
cool sa
[Music]
poter my my son is reading Chamber of
Secrets right
now and that we just we just read that
part in the flourish and
blots s Potter can't even go to Bookshop
without making the front page
all right all right you got a little bit
more no he he's down but I'm
suspended he he fires him a lot more
[Applause]
rapid oh come
on get up get up get up get up get up
get up get
[Music]
up come on Harry all right we got to
quit playing
around dude he's using all these he's
doing what I'm doing no the AI is not
supposed to be smart enough for
that come on
ah oh did that backfire on him it looked
like
it
arm oh come on
[Music]
Harry
wait for
it
[Music]
what
super please there we go all
right
nice back to back all right here we go
that was good caught him while he was
charging it
up dude you can even fire them you can
fire them a little bit
faster as long as you don't spam more
than
three
oh come
[Music]
on all right haret let's just let's just
end
this oh what a Proto right there that
was actually
nice
come on we just need one of these to hit
there it
is
sheesh where is
Maloy somewhere you w't find him to tell
him that stupid doesn't M there you
there you don't have to miss him you
just Scout
[Music]
one yeah the just hearing them
constantly porter porter porter nah it's
got to be Porter not poter
Porter what do you think you're doing
Porter that's how I imagine crab and
[__] all right so we know how to do this
one now we just drop it right
break dude that's actually I that's a
clever puzzle I like that now we can
repair
it cuz like you would think to try and
wing guardiam it to bring it over but I
would I don't think I would ever think
oh I need to break this so it will fit
through the
bars most modern games when you see a
gate like that your natural instinct is
be like okay how do we get that gate to
open essentially how do we get that gate
down all right so there's another one up
there let's see do we have something we
can throw at
it it still cracks me up that you can't
use wingu guardium Leviosa when they're
just hanging out up there oh wait is
this book
maybe oh a chair that
works that
works I don't know why this one keeps
spinning like
that wait
what I didn't mean to pick you up oh
that might be part of the puzzle that we
need to actually open this and leave
this
area come on
yeah there we
go 78 out of
150 okay so yeah this little thing right
here we just picked
up now this these are the kinds of
things like I'll I'll try to figure out
on my
own I won't look at chat for a bit you
guys can say it but I'm not going to
look for a
moment all right so what did he say he
said we need to we need to figure out
how to open this right
does it tell me anywhere oh wait I see I
see I
see all right can we fit
you through the
bars not you get
away
you now see if it was like Hogwarts
Legacy we could position I this just
right to fit it through the
bars
H yeah the YouTube inquisitorial Squad
they're going to be all over this
section right
here any section where there's music
guys the YouTube inquisitorial Squad
they they hit us after the
Stream
H
okay yeah it looks
pretty there really not a lot of not a
gap I mean there's kind of a gap at the
bottom all right maybe there's one of
these switches on our
[Music]
side can we repair any of
this now that's the
chair all right hold on just tell me
this guys just just just answer this
much for me are we supposed to go
through here right now is this where
they told me to go I should have been
paying closer
attention I'm going to give it a second
cuz I don't want to see if if the answer
has been
posted but uh I just want to know is
this am I supposed to get through here
through this gate right here
or am I supposed to do something else
like going going up the stairs here okay
yes all right all right all right all
right we're good we're good then we're
going to figure this out
here okay so thinking of all the spells
that we have we've got this this this
book flying
around I don't know if that's supposed
to be something that we're supposed to
use or
not hey Mercia thank you so much for the
super chat your first ever Super Chat on
a stream let's go thank you so much my
apology if I mispronounced the name
there
Mercia thank you very much I don't see a
message with your Super Chat there so it
looks like you were just super chatting
to uh out of your own generosity thank
you very much it means means a lot I
really do appreciate that and I hope you
are enjoying hanging out and watching
the
stream as I struggle with with this this
little puzzle
here all right I mean I feel like that's
definitely like we we have to get it
I've got presents we have to use this
handle on
that so we need to get this gate open
all right what are some ways we could
get gates open you think about games you
got like there's lots of
switches Mac and chees welcome to the
stream welcome
welcome okay so think about how it works
with the crest here you drop and break
the crest can we drop and break hold on
can we break
this come on I need you to lift up
higher than
that it's not going to break from that
far dang
it come on break
it
and see you can't really it's not like
Hogwarts Legacy guys it doesn't really
give me control over a
verticality it's kind of just just
here whoa I don't know what that
was all right I'm getting close to
asking for a
hint I'm not there yet not there yet but
I'm but I'm getting close let me see if
oh wait current objective current
objective let's see what it says on this
well hello
there well here we
are thank you
Nick appreciate you man exactly what I
needed exactly what I needed
Nick like we don't even have there's not
even much to work with here we've got
this little we've got this little key
right here we've got this book okay wait
hold on let's try this are we supposed
to like knock the book with the key I
don't know how that would relate see I
can't even I can't even control the okay
wait
wait did it just
break
dude no
way I am shocked that that
worked see they're tricky though man
they're like oh we're going to give you
this mechanic with the
crests that that's actually
cool that is pretty cool
raro I like that a lot actually what a
great
puzzle cuz that was just like there's
nothing else in this room man for us to
work with nothing else in this
room
we got there
chat we got there it took us a
while but we got
there so crab Max how's it going welcome
in what's strange about that malire
wasn't with them sometimes he's not even
visible on the Marauders Mac in the
house too fat Jedi I mean he can't just
disappear can
he
maybe her is right maybe I should forget
about Mala and concentrate on slug horn
but how am I supposed to get to his
memory I don't even know what a h Crux
is run beautiful isn't it the moon um
yeah I can't stop thinking about her
Harry I love her do you think she wonder
what's going on here well she's been
Snogging you for months
snugging I've never snugged Raa
rilda Ron did you eat these chocolates
they're from rilda vain they're full of
love potion
rilda do you know Harry can you
introduce me yeah she's uh she's in Slug
Horn's office yes she's definitely
har good
thinking hi Ron have you done your
potion's homework M you're a girl I'm
surprised you noticed
Ronald do you think rlda would like
flowers or chocolates don't mind him he
ate some love potion I'm taking him to
sorn's office to see
rlda a
Raa bro love potion Man follow here wait
you take control of Ron what is this
what is happening right now
look look at the
walk oh my
gosh you can tell the devs were having
fun with this man they're like okay
there's a couple ways we can handle this
part let's just put them in control of
Ron okay we can't actually run
nice and just have look at look at look
at that man wait I got to get him walk
get him walking toward the
camera
Dylan what's up dude Dylan with the
Super Chat stay idle for a bit oh no
way oh sorry put put the wand away Ron
put it away it looked like he was about
to start dancing or something and then I
think I messed it up by pulling out the
wand Dylan appreciate the Super Chat
dude let's see if he'll do it with the
wand
[Music]
oh come on
Ron wait wait wait there you
[Music]
go no
way all right this game is quickly
ramping not ramping this game is quickly
moving up my
list of best Harry Potter
games
bro that is to too
funny all right yeah we might as well
get these two see I didn't even know you
could you could use the one when you're
in this state and their hearts as
well what that is so funny
dude you think about how dangerous Love
Potion really is
though I mean if somebody never
knew like I'm sure a well trained po ER
could could do a much better job than
the one to like like Ron Harry was
immediately able to tell like okay
something's way
off but I would say that there are ways
to disguise it I mean isn't that how
Voldemort
was
um what's a what's a PG way we could say
this that's is how Voldemort came into
being was the result of a love
[Music]
potion
CU it's like it's something you think
it's just like this is a a hilarious
moment
right but is actually a a Darkness to to
love potions man and what
they cuz it's it's it's usually going to
be used for somebody I mean why else
would you need it if it's other than
against their
will I cannot believe they put this into
the game though this is
great oh no one on I've been looking for
you I got you leave me alone har is
going to introduce me to R Dain on what
I'll explain
later was it Tom Riddle Senor was it not
actually Tom am I forgetting
that I knew it was somewhere in
Voldemort's uh family history sorry to
bother you sir I need some help where is
she what's the matter with wbe Weasley
sir Raa that's a pretty name for pretty
witch he's accidentally taken some love
potion I see the problem come in I've
got the then it's about to get even
darker with what's happening next it's
not a difficult antidote I think we'
better make it
quickly oh make it quickly all right all
right all right all right all right uh
whatever these things are these
little no no no no no I I got to
remember that I don't have to move
it all right
stir this would be a good one to get in
under 35 but I don't think we're going
to be able I think it's got too many
ingredients I think we need something
that doesn't have as many to be able to
get that
trophy 35 seconds man that's quick all
right then we need at least it doesn't
smell as bad as it tastes wait is it
this
one or is it this one I think it's this
one all right get a little
bubbly oh great wakey
wakey because it stopped bubbling is
that why it started doing that on on
[Music]
me bro the shaking ones I am not quite
enough smoke not doing a great job with
oh man we're we're about to run out of
time come on come on turn purple
quickly I don't think that's going to
get me an
outstanding come on
now I'm sorry to bother you sir I need
some help where is she what's the matter
with wbe Weasley wait romilda is no way
Arvin he's accidentally taken some love
potions I see the problem I've seen all
the Witcher Seasons I never put that
together it's not a difficult I'm going
have to go back and look think we she
looks way different in in The
[Music]
Witcher okay one the shaking ones guys
I'm there's something that I'm missing
I'm not doing right I don't know what it
is but oh
steady wins the race
man this makes the title for today's
stream even better huh becoming a
potions
master all right there it is stop stop
stop you're good at this aren't
you all right so I need to shake
it this next one we're going to
shake until it bubbles but then yeah I
was asking you guys there's no
indication for like how long I need to
pour that's what I was asking so you
never know if you're going to have to
pour for like a really long
time there we go or a really short
[Music]
time
nice okay that one again only this time
we're not shaking
it see like that time I almost got it
too
far cuz it is not red as it should
should have been you are doing very well
my boy another one of those okay almost
there keep up for good work extract of I
need
this
thing I think that's
it where's the
bubbly oh jeez almost messed it
up right there all right another one
this time no
shaking
stir all right these the last ones look
look easy here I think we should be
good
excellent Jenny have a good one thank
you for being
here enjoy the rest of your work
day oh you said you'll be back in a
little got
you one of
these oh my gosh got so much time
wonderful all right again not the best
but
hey if it's
successful I'll take it I will take
it fill up to the black line on the
inside of the cauldron fill up to the
black line fine all right my boy oh so
that's like an that's like every time
what happened to me love potion I feel
really bad drink this and a little pick
me up for you too
Potter run dude this part was crazy in
the what what poisoned he's been
[Music]
poisoned AB way more serious than that
just Mak you got save W's life my boy
ah way more serious in the
[Music]
book
myy what was she doing here anyway one
one I your girlfriend yeah um have you
seen him
ony oops pity you can't make a potion to
help run with lavender Brown it was
lucky you thought of that bizor last
night Harry it was lucky there was one
in the room come on it's almost time for
the match against Hufflepuff I'll see
you at the quiddit pitch it's almost
time for the match against Hufflepuff
never mind that somebody just tried to
murder Ron it's all good we don't need
to worry about that right now guys that
is not our Focus
slug horn the teacher just standing
there like what do I
do I'm a potions mastered
up I get it I know guys I'm just I'm
just giving him a hard time I know the
game has to move
on but it's still funny to go from a
scene where your best friend was just
nearly
murdered and they G game's like oh yeah
you got that uh quidd is match against
hpff dude don't
forget good don't forget it's time for
quit a cherry I know I'm going the wrong
way guys but I remembered somebody said
they told us they told us how to get
this one right
here that is crazy to me that is crazy
to me that that's all we had to
do that is crazy to me man that was
lonus wasn't it lonus appreciate
it huh no way did you
find Ron would want the man to go on go
on
Harry it's you that has to go on I know
it just go you're wasting
[Music]
time all right the quiddit hold on I'm
going to need Nick for this Nick the
route to get there is like t for waiting
for you we go to the allery right good
luck it's not the direction you would
expect Derek how's it stacking up with
Chamber of Secrets man like I would
going into it Derek I would have said no
way it even close morning time for
breakfast I'd say o I'm so
hungry I don't know man I don't know I I
still I still think as as of this moment
I would put chamber above
it I played the GameCube version of
chamber but I am I'm really enjoying
this one so far part of it could be
because I had set my expectations a bit
lower after I was disappointed with
Order of the
Phoenix but I really do think think they
fixed a lot of the issues which is kind
of crazy because
uh actually don't know I can't remember
how well this one
reviewed Bo boiled beetles boiled boiled
boiled yes they'd like that would they
oh yeah the other guy's voice in order
the Phoenix was better on
that Tom game on the Wii such a a fun
childhood
memory I played so I played when I was
growing up I played Order of the Phoenix
on the we I he Weasley's in the hospital
yes he's then you'll need a new keeper
and as I was best in the trials I'll see
you in the air
all right Cormac Ron was best at the
trials but we're stuck with
you quiditch time ladies and gentlemen
quiddit
time 7.5 so that was pretty solid for
these
games I think that was definitely higher
than uh or did they give War of the
phoenix like an eight or something
[Applause]
Dylan
oh I nearly missed that
one wait are we just warming up or are
we actually playing the match I think
we're warming up before the
[Applause]
match yeah I don't see the other
team 7.3 for order the Phoenix so they
had them pretty
close I mean I just think this one
is far and way the
Phoenix I haven't beaten it yet so we'll
see see practice catching a snitch
come on I'm trying to come on trying to
catch the
snitch I left you guys hanging there
with that impression I can't
believe Joseph heading out hey Joseph
appreciate you being here have a good
one by the way guys anybody in the
replay Squad if you guys come back and
watch this later in the
replay let me know in the comments below
today we're going to post a let's go
with a broom
Emoji broom Emoji in the comments for
the people watching this video later let
me know you made it this far into the
video but yeah I left you guys hanging
on the impression I didn't I didn't do
the most iconic line from that
scene which apparently I've been seeing
this in a lot of
uh like memes and stuff
lately you guys know the line you guys
know the
line you guys know the
line not
me not
Amy you
it's you that has to go on I know it not
me not
herione
you oh man so
good what game is this no not Hogwarts
Legacy Beats by Fred no no this is Half
Blood Prince on the PlayStation
3 Ivy you better be careful about where
you say that
the the WB uh you signed an NDA if you
were part of that play
[Applause]
test but you're not the only one who
shared their Impressions the opposition
SE I've heard uh I've heard both
actually I've heard some people who
really loved
it some people who
didn't HFF buff
score puffle buff score already that was
so
small why is Jenny like falling jinny
you you can like I I I can take it from
here
business she's like no
hurry must lead you to the
[Applause]
snitch the match out of my way dude out
of my way
help out of my way
nice
move for position I do wish with the
Quidditch they had given you a little
bit more
control I mean it it pretty much is just
flying through the Rings
which yeah
now for all the people who wanted
quiddit in Hog's Legacy let me ask you
this would you have been fine like would
you have liked it if it was literally
just something like this like something
that was just very on
Rails and you only really play one
position because the more I listen to
people I think I think people would have
been fine with just this but see in my
mind I was always like well if we want
quit itch wouldn't you guys want like a
full-fledged the is like more quid Royal
Cup Style letting you play other even
letting you play other positions go
against other
peopleit because looking back at these
games I remember everybody just being
like talking positively about the
Quidditch like just enjoying that it was
there in any capacity that was brilliant
well done everyone allegedly yeah yeah
there you go I be back from hospital
soon you heard he'll be back you heard
people talking about it sorry M well
played everyone
[Music]
oh it's all good Dylan I don't think
they would I don't think they would uh
come after us but yeah good good call
anyway to be sure tell me again how I
broke up with lavender don't get me
wrong I'm I'm bloody thrilled we did
it's just she seemed a bit put out don't
you remember anything from that night oh
honestly Ron it's not my fault I was
poisoned must be a side effect well
you're not the only one out of Hospital
ktie Bell is back I saw her in the great
hall now we can find out who gave her
that necklace she can tell us who cursed
her yeah Garrett this one was pretty
much on I it was not just on PS3 I think
it was on uh I know for sure it was on
Xbox and was it on a Nintendo yeah it
was it was on the Wii it was on the Wii
as well and then uh
PC all right
so I think now we should learn that that
spell paved Courtyard that's where Wario
that we need to go all right Nick lead
the way my
friend I know the music that will if you
guys are watching this on the replay you
may not hear music the YouTube
inquisitorial Squad as we calling
them makes it so I may have to remove
[Music]
that oh my goodness ladies and gentlemen
look who has just joined
us graced us with her
presence it is
Alicia love good
Alicia
14mon
membership Alicia always good to see you
and chat with you welcome in how you
been doing what's going
on oh no I didn't actually mean to grab
that but you know what since that little
Crest is right there I think we might as
well do
it Alicia did you ever play this one
Half Blood
Prince I'm having a blast with
it I'm having a blast just I know I've
said it a couple times already guys but
much more than I
expected all right let's hit
that any others in the area
[Music]
C
inspector you like this version of the
grand
staircase more than uh Hogwarts
Legacy what is that you guys like about
it more she said it looks more like the
movies well you may have beaten our
Junior Champion but I bet there's one
spell you can't do very well petrificus
totalus I can do that you use it to
paralyze your opponent it's all good all
good you're lying no I'm not I'll show
you you didn't have the OG consoles the
oldest one you play was the Lego games
gotcha all right petrius total is to
disable your opponent like this all
right so we need to both of the
joysticks going inward all
right
[Music]
toal
so you can cast it well done not as
stylishly as a slithering can cast it
though the Keen duelist badge ladies and
gentlemen we have just
graduated and now have access to the
final spell is that not a trophy for
real I figured that'd be a trophy for
learning the final spell yep all right
so we got everything
what what excuse me did we not just
learn oh
no something glitch know that Katy Bell
is back she has returned from St [__]
and looking n the worst no no no I don't
want to do that yet Nick did we do
something
wrong it was in the we were paved
Courtyard okay sther IND dueling Club
maybe we just need to at your chosen
some I could be of service spell is nice
for getting rid of some health on the
opponent nice I just now I just need to
figure out what did I do something
wrong Shacks welcome to the stream oh
that's
princess princess welcome back good to
see you I've been doing well doing well
always good to see you stop by the
streams and say
hello oh I see inspector yeah yeah
yeah I see what you mean
a I mean let's be honest none of them
have actually been able to
capture oh well hello there's a Crest
right
here exactly how it would be in the
books but they also have to make it work
I mean the movies they had to make it
work for visuals the game they have to
make it work for things like progression
you know and making sure that things
flow well and make sense and people
don't get lost
but yeah I I don't I don't feel
particularly strong strongly one way or
the other um but but you are not alone I
I've definitely heard several different
people on both sides like I saw Anna
saying she likes the Hogwarts Legacy one
more I guess just something I haven't
really uh thought as deeply about as
some others all right this is worrying
me what what did we do wrong why did we
not why did it not give us leoc
corpus
yeah exactly Arvin yes I'm rubbish at
Transfiguration I
wish oh Christian gamer yeah that's
another one people love to
discuss is the
music honestly like I don't even need to
pit them against each other I I think
they're both great man I think Hogwarts
Legacy absolutely crushed with the music
I love the
music I'm glad they didn't just use the
same music I know a lot of people said
hey they should have used the same no no
no no let this let this music exist here
in these
games you can always go back and play
them and hear the music here which was
great I mean it was great no doubt oh
no
okay
do we just not burn it all the
way cuz it's not letting me use
wingardium let's see does it grow back
again it does okay hold
on we got to be quick I guess all right
so let's turn and face
you and then we got to quickly grab the
dung
bomb come on turn oh
no
it's going to be too late I knew it
man
oh
okay all
right Crest collector number 10 as well
let's go moving on up with the
trophies oh jeez
jez okay so the Blackboard is where we
go to duel so do I have to duel I guess
even though I I just did petrificus
totalis maybe we have to do one of the
Duss before it
will fully give it to us and now bear
witness to the victory of sli's Junior
Champion against potty Potter poty we
Potter
I'm going to try it right away first
first first
spell okay we got it all
right your Junior Champion I'm just
going to go ahead and tell you
man he's going to get absolutely
wrecked wait now it deflects off what is
that so does it still hurt him though
hold on
[Music]
ready get up get up get up get up get up
I think we just beat him anyway yeah we
[Music]
[Applause]
did right inspector but it like it
wasn't appearing in the
menu that's what was throwing me off it
was um or it did appear in the menu but
it was still gray
out
oh nice that was a good
[Music]
hitf
toal oh so it does still hurt them but
then
deflects when they're in petrificus
that's all right now that we did it I'm
going to pull up the menu again and
let's see if it's
gray out I'll show you guys what I was
talking
about final score
2,14 oh it does like a damage overtime
thing so it's not actually I'm not
actually hitting them then
interesting yeah now let's check it and
see yeah yeah see now it's now it's
wait dude it was it was there at first
wasn't it it's like some visual bug
watch this see how it shows right there
that I have it but then when I go over
it that's crazy then it
just very strange all right well we got
it
though we got
it hen edits playing this on the Wii was
so fun he got you the movements yeah I
didn't I played uh order the Phoenix on
the
Wii but more recently I played it on the
PS3 and the the waggle is the waggle
with the right analog stick is not very
intuitive yet for this
game it still doesn't feel
great but I feel like the way they
structured the spells it works it works
better in this one for
me got a little Crest right here oh man
I love it when you get to the first
try I love it when it pops in the first
try all right I'm just going to look
around for a little
bit actually you know what I know what
we could do here let's check the
trophies no not that let's see where
we're at I think it was under
PlayStation Network last time right yeah
trophy collection oh that's right we we
have to wait on the
sink
we have to wait for the old school
sinking with the
PlayStation
server all right well give me chance to
stretch a bit here to take a sip of my
Coke Zero make sure to stay hydrated
ladies and gentlemen yeah I hope you
guys are having a wonderful Tuesday so
far my kids finally went back to school
today they had been out
for
um they kept having snow
days because we were having lots of snow
and then just really really cold in our
area yeah I want to get a little uh
check on our progress here see how
things are
looking
78% cheat movie tie in game made by EA
of course there going to be
glitches honestly that's I think that's
like the first
one I feel like the uh order Order of
the Phoenix on PS3 was way had had a lot
of just annoying
bugs all right we're still only at
41% okay
41% the great party I thought that said
the great Perry at first all right so
these are probably Story related then
cuz that one help Ron with
lavender ooh hide the Half Blood
princess potion book that's probably got
to be Story related too so that's going
to be one two three four I'm guessing
those four are going to carry us to the
end of the story Adventure completed
that'll be for concluding get beating
the
game and then so we've gotten 10 Crest
collectors so far okay so there's only
four more of
those hold on a second do you even have
to get all of the
crests yeah you probably do right you
probably have to get all of
them then we need the Speedy Brewer so
somebody said for that one we need to
brew a potion in less than 35 seconds
potions Club star or in the potions Club
star badge I have no idea how you do
that one potions Club veteran I'm
guessing these are tied to the clubs and
then Master potioneer that's a gold
those are probably all
three in the potions Club
reflex badge no idea how to do that one
dueling Champion okay so yeah I bet
these are all tied to the
dueling reflex badge though that one
almost sounds like something specific I
have to do with
timing and then you have the Keen flyer
badge two two badges for flying okay so
it looks like we've got I mean it's just
going to be
potions it's going to be
dueling beating the game obviously
and then the
crests which is kind of what what I was
anticipating anyway so it doesn't look
like there's anything to out
there that we're going to be
missing I could go after I kind of want
to go for one of these flying
trophies let's
see or you know what no let's just let's
just stay focused on the
story cuz we might be able to beat the
game today actually let's talk to Katie
milons if you hurry you should catch you
guys have had rain a lot in Arizona
Dylan you had freezing rain yeah I feel
like the weather across the US these
past like week and a
half has been pretty
crazy yeah we still have snow on the
ground that hasn't
melted oh wait a second
crest
incendio I probably should have figured
out what I'm going to knock it down with
first hold on Nick should we bring
something from there it is right there
we can use
you I'm going to see if this works again
so remember how on the last one even
after it oh that does that one just stay
gone okay that is so strange why does
the other one grow
back and that one stays gone hey I'm not
complaining
though I'm not complaining one
bit
[Music]
I'm man the music is
fire it is
[Music]
fire were was this one all done by
Jeremy Soul as well I know he did the
first actually no this one was somebody
else because
I it pops up when the uh YouTube
inquisitorial
Squad shows up on my videos after
[Music]
stream Mayo welcome in never played
these games yes the PO Mayo that has
surprisingly been one of my favorite
parts of the game and and honestly
pretty challenging how are you KY give
me a moment I know you're going to ask
but I don't know who cursed me I've
tried to remember but I just
can't I just
can't is that it are we are we done
here next objective
okay I was waiting for more to happen
there usually there's like another story
thing hold on let me try to talk to her
again
nothing wait is that Malo over there I
think that's Draco we probably just have
to leave and then something's going to
trigger hold on Draco one moment dude
let me grab these little mini crests
here
and then I'll be right with you sir I'll
be right with
you touch nothing
Draco
he's like a a tank man you can't keep
hiding it's hard for him to make Quick
Cuts wait okay I guess we actually have
you actually have to stay on him give me
a moment no way I know you're going to
ask but you cursed me I've tried to
remember but I just
can't all right
Draco get lost get lost
all right I'm guessing you don't
actually catch him you just have to
follow him to a specific
spot all right slow down here it's like
Mario Kart or something man to get
around the tight turns break break
break bro
Draco he's been running track in his uh
in between figuring out that Vanishing
cabinet
no Harry don't slow down
dude Harry my man you got to go upstairs
faster than
that run up to a banner uh no I don't
think I will at this
moment we've got other things to worry
about
[Music]
there we go just leave me alone
pter oh here we go dude here we
go oh come on no way he could Dodge that
maybe we'll actually have a challenging
duel though
now he's pretty aggressive that the best
you can
[Music]
do oh my goodness yeah he's really
aggressive come on
[Music]
Harry
shees there we go
super Mercy is fight better he's ahead
right now come on get up get up get up
get up get up get up get up get up get
up come on cast
[Music]
oh it's tied actually I might be one
ahead I know I could use Pego
but for me the timing on Pego is never
never
[Music]
right nice there we
go
cruy SE
SE don't touch me don't you dare touch
me we need to get you to the hospital
wing and you poter where did you learn
that
spell I it was in a library book liar
you are to gather all your school books
all of them and bring them to me here
immediately
so I gave Ron's book to Snape instead
and you used a spell you didn't
recognize on drao I didn't mean to he
was trying to curse me and I I just you
have to get rid of the book and I know
just where you can hide
it oh that's a trophy
remember the room of requirement oh man
please don't make this as awkward as it
was in this is where you come Order of
the
Phoenix close your
eyes
there now no will find
it
Harry I've got a secret
too okay it wasn't as awkward wasn't as
awkward so did you and jinny do it what
the book oh yeah somewhere in the room
of requirements even I don't know where
it is well I think it's a good thing I
using an untested spell on someone I
know at least you can concentrate on
your proper mission for Dumbledore you
haven't had much luck so far have you no
but maybe luck is what it will
take it's time I got lucky the comedic
timing on that they nailed
it all right here we
go oh no way well how do you
feel great in fact I think I'll take a
walk to the herbology green houses you
need to find slow corn my
gosh trust me I know what I'm doing it's
going to be like the wrong
scene are
we what first person
what what the heck is going on I really
must
pay what dude oh my goodness we can
first person Harry Potter
what
[Music]
what who knew man there was a first
person Harry Potter game all
[Music]
along I'm feeling
this just strolling through Hogwarts man
getting these little mini
crests this looks like a mod or
something it doesn't look like it's
actually part of the
game excuse me sir don't mind
me oh you will get more than
normal no way oh how do we get this one
I don't think we can't get that so
clever attacking Draco like that he was
going to use cruciatus on with another
Super Chat on you hey thank you dude
appreciate it D collect all the mini
Crest oh my gosh like everything
hits everything
hits seriously Dylan appreciate the
Super Chat man collect all the mini
Crest what's wrong Goyle is I have Felix
felus my friend
just like everything
hits I think I can just Spam
it
wrecked the reflex badge that was a
trophy he's done something I can't hit
him oh get him there it is there it
[Music]
is oh you can't even get hit here that's
great
[Music]
dude if it was this powerful like why
didn't they
just you just need everybody to take
some Felix felis before the uh the final
battle like see that one actually hit me
but it didn't even
register jeez you won't be so lucky next
time PA I don't need luck to beat
you here we go I just wanted to see what
it would do if we charged up the spell
and it did not
disappoint he is op man this is like
when you get the cheat codes at the end
of the of a
game and your character is just way
overleveled Felix felicis my
friends oh there's another one right
there dude we got to remember this I
don't even know what CT over in right
okay just off the Transfiguration
Courtyard out of my way
sir so you can look around but that's
really all you can control and then you
can you can activate the mini
crests and apparently we earn way more
right now than
[Music]
normal man see like this this is like
the heart of the game
right I think I feel like that's what
was missing from Order of the Phoenix
like the
spirit which I didn't love the Half
Blood prins movie but man this is they
really
got what made this story so
strong and like adapted it to a way
that's like funny in a video game that's
a venomous tentacular Merlin's beard its
leaves are quite valuable aren't they
yes I'm not interested in selling them
of course my interest is p purely
academic not that this specimen would
fetch many gallions have you tried using
a dragon dung fertilizer on it you think
that would work oh yes I have a feeling
it
will all right sloth
brain oh a little bit more wonderful
wonderful
come
on Sunshine Daisy butter mellow turn
this stupid
yellow what is
[Music]
that
fertilizer excellent oh we're making
fertilizer oh no we got to shake this
one you guys know I do not farewell with
[Music]
these hey we actually got
it oh yeah you oh can you mess up this
potion I thought you meant normally and
that's a good question I don't know
about this
one I'd say you probably can
but keep those eyelids open almost there
keep up the good
work my time is just sitting there at
100 oh there he goes finally started
ticking down oh come
on the potion goes perfectly doesn't
punish you for wrong moves thanks Yahoo
yeah I figured it would have to do
something
heyy starer Tim what's up dude welcome
in did you ever play this one Tim stewed
Mandrake quieter than the live
[Music]
version why does it start doing that
like it makes me sound like a death
eater's in the
room what what is it just a potion I
picked up it wants me to know hey this
is a serious potion right
here serious
ingredi man this potion requires so
much almost there keep up for good
work okay what is that this
[Music]
one wonderful the
rat
one and two excellent toasted dragonfly
thoraxes
wonderful
wonderful I love how you hear the
mandres in the
background yeah i' Hogwarts
Legacy up the good
work definitely could have used some
potion brewing like like I enjoy that
man it is like a mini game and you know
I know a lot of people don't love like
little add-on minii games all the time
but for me this one has been try it
sir it's not been like too much of it I
feel like they've done a good job
spreading it too but you shouldn't be
walking about at night Harry actually
sir I'm just about to go for a walk down
to hagrids I'm sorry but I can't allow
you to go off walking the castle grounds
alone well come with me sir by all means
come with me
[Music]
sir Chan are you
watching like the sound oh is that what
it is lius I knew you'd come to M old
aragog my oldest friend he
was aragog a giant spider an acroman
what's up Warrior welcome counted him as
a friend even though it tried to eat
me he was just being
friendly hag not to be oh I love hag
acromantula Venom is very valuable would
you mind if I extracted a vial or two
then maybe spoke a few words over the
decease oh
aragog I'll miss you old friend the
movies did nail this the whole Felix Fel
well aragog king of
arachnids descendants ever flourish a
toast to the funeral of a friend I'm so
sorry for your loss
Hagrid oh we got a Crest on the to ar ar
in the Hut do you know
[Music]
why
on the Hagrid's Hut here boom first
try let's go 90 crests okay can we go
inside
here H
grid maybe this way this
way
nope
no come on I'm trying
to get the crest I don't want any more
pumpkins hor is just standing there it's
like I think I'll just wait here H this
I think this should be a Crest over
here yeah there's a lot that we didn't
get yetc pretty much all the ones that
have incendio we've only gotten a few of
those cuz we unlocked that near the end
of
our part one of the
stream make sure there's not anything
back here near near Old
aragog yes that's the name Yahoo that's
the name that keeps popping
up when the YouTube inquisitorial Squad
shows
up okay that that's a Crest right
okay hold
on maybe we have to throw something at
that
one I don't know it doesn't look like a
Crest but then I mean it does look like
a Crest
but I don't want any more pumpkins no no
no we're good we're good we got enough
pumpkins and yet here I am back with
another pumpkin
hey freaking nerds Mario welcome dude
it's your favorite film and you never
played the game man dude I'd never
played it
either and the chat's probably sick of
hearing me say it but I'll say it again
like I I've been so pleasantly
[Music]
surprised
[Laughter]
[Music]
come to them and then go for the rest at
the
end yeah I once I play all the Potter
games which I still have quite a few to
go but once I play all of them I need to
do a big
ranking tier tier list video cuz right
now I mean my top one like if we're
counting Hogwarts Legacy it's obviously
Hogwarts Legacy but if we're only
counting like games with Harry Potter in
them which I have to specify dude people
in the comments man they'd be getting
they be getting so
angry Dylan
knows if I'm like like I did a poll you
guys may remember seeing this poll I had
a poll up I was like best Harry Potter
game of all
time and I didn't put Hogwarts Legacy in
there because I was I was specifically
asking about games featuring The
playable boy who lived Harry
Potter and I don't know if it's an
exaggeration to say half the comments
were like uh Hogwarts Legacy the fact
that Hogwarts Legacy is not on this list
is a travesty I kid you I kid you not
man people getting angry I'm like
guys I
said I said Harry Potter
like and I'm not trying to be like cute
with the definitions I just I I just I
just literally mean
games when when you're controlling this
guy this man right here that's what I
was talking about that's that's
all like yes I consider I I say Hogwart
cacy yeah it's it's it's a game part of
the Harry Potter Universe
absolutely but like that particular poll
my friends I was specifically asking
just about Potter games so next time man
next time if I ever do that poll again
I'm going to be very very specific with
with how I phrase
it yeah I think I got mine highq Warrior
I bought this the PS3 version on eBay
look who's still creeping about I
haven't got time for this you're going
nowhere
St
kidding
me that should do it that should do it
make you pay putter M to lose a father
in aapan before he ever beats me sir
I've got it I've got the memory from
this is spectacular I knew you could do
it Harry Qui so
good oh we're just going straight we're
just going straight into the memory they
don't waste time now at last we shall
see poor
cruxes that's very dark stuff indeed
Tom to make one you would have to split
your soul and to do that well murder
killing rips the soul Soul apart to
think of doing that once is a violation
against nature but seven
times so Horus told Tom Riddle about
horcruxes you see a horcrux is an object
in which a person has concealed part of
their soul let me tell you and while the
hux exists that person cannot
die the ominous look do you think that's
what V what has done he succeeded in
making a HW Crux oh he succeeded and not
just once he made seven he tore his soul
into seven pieces one resides within him
the other six you uncounted one hwr here
in your second year Tom Riddle's Diary I
have accounted for another in the form
of this ring that's how you hurt your
hand and that's where you've been going
to search for the h cruxes yes har and I
think perhaps I have found the third
when the time comes I shall need your
help to destroy
it oh dude we're getting closer
man and snake's making you do the
detention no he knows it's the deciding
match you'll have to fly instead of me
Dean can take your place as
Chaser gossiping when you should be
waiting by my office
Potter that will be 10 points from
griffindor what what for I'm not late
I'm not late sir there's no need to call
me sir Professor I would have thought
you had enough detentions after the
incident with Draco
Maloy that was actually wasn't that a
bookline 20 points from
griffindor and go to my office
Gryffindor just have a manage without
their chosen one if it gind fourth place
in the Quidditch Cup this year I fear
win that match jinny win the cup for
Gryffindor his beard speaks yeah tumors
let his beard speak for him where's
Harry snake made him do detention I'm
flying a Seeker today great if we win
this game we could win the cup that's
what I promised Harry we would do we are
going to win the cup stop being so sulky
and let's look at the notice board for
the warm up how yeah I thought I
remembered that as a book line now we
going to get to play
J
if so that'll be pretty
cool yeah they nailed the
sassiness they did guys they did oh we
do get SPL jny I mean it's the same
thing as far as the flying
goes but that's pretty cool that they
you get to play as her and still still
play the
[Applause]
match you can do
it
last quidditch match for the
game keep going you can get this
SP excellent
[Music]
D
uhoh I wonder if any of these flying
challenges actually difficult because I
mean I don't even think I've had a ring
turn red like get close
to
missing oh oh I was trying to look at
Chad I shouldn't have done it I usually
don't look more were flying but I was
like oh here we go a nice little
straight away I can glance
over see if there's anything I need to
respond to but and I started
missing
who that was a little
confusing oh my goodness so many of
these
dudes
watch out behind
you all right I'm warmed up let's start
this
match yikes okay we go we got it we got
it yeah Mayo it looks pretty solid and
it's you know just running straight on
PS3 no kind of emulation or or no
Uprising or anything like
that all right so now we get to play the
actual
match dude they even got the students up
there you see
[Applause]
them the big match begins uh Jay-Z
welcome dude winner it's been a while
Jay-Z good to see
you okay
so a great CR Gryffindor versus Raven
craw I'm
on oh
missed I don't think they're talking
about
me hope I don't think we
[Music]
missed
yikes a real tle
here those are tough when you have to go
right next to the hoop and are in r or
sometimes through the
[Music]
hoop that was a good
[Applause]
touch wait you shouldn't be able allow
allowed to leave the the pitch like this
the Rival Seeker is snitches way
out
gen is put in oh I was trying to go
[Music]
under both teams are as good as each
other it will be out of my way out of my
way out of my
way yeah they're heading back into the
stadium look out jny
and the head
[Applause]
that's all right if Raven claws
ahead because we're playing the most
overpowered
position in the sport that's a state
clim
look now come on come on grab
[Applause]
ites no I thought we were that was a
great SA staying down staying down okay
okay okay still staying down yep oh we
missed that
one the two Seekers are going Head to
Head bro we're still supposed to stay
down
here what a
sa
what all right the snitch is definitely
oh no no no there's a red one I think we
missed one
somewhere
oh this one's definitely been the most
challenging so
far but I think we're getting close no
two more R destroy these flies close
together four more Rings R for a contest
here oh no way did we miss that one I
think we
did
fantastic it's also probably the longest
one by
far grab it grab it grab it will win the
quid
C oh no we got two of them over here
three of them over
here I'll get it for
you the only way you can lose the match
right is if you
don't get through all the
ring or you let one like snitch is
C there we go final quick match complete
let's go
congratulations point to each and every
one of you wait can you do
that job well done what happened what
happened we won how was the detention
huh oh snake Champion trophy worms tell
the rest of the team congratulations for
me will you you can tell them yourself I
can't dumbledor asked to meet me at the
astronomy Tower I think he wants me to
go with him to look for a h Crux wait
is it time already his note want me to
take some wig andwell potion first let's
go I better get going to potions Club to
make some I'll see you later oh one more
potion though one more
potion go to potions club and brew a
Wigan well potion hey Nick Dumbledore
wants me to make a Wigan World potion
well if the head has you think you'd
actually lose in the in the portable
ones that's cool you should make your
way to the potions Club in the herbology
Mayo yeah dude I was asking people
earlier about that in another when we
were playing earlier and had a quidditch
match like if Hogwarts Legacy had done
quidditch like that right there where
it's literally just kind of an on Rails
mini game would you have would you have
been happy with that cuz I feel like
most
people actually I don't know man I don't
know I mean cuz that's what it is it's
really just it's a very basic on Rails
mini game
essentially oh no the wigg and weld's
the hardest one to make
all right who do we need to talk to here
or do we
just Metatron absolutely no yeah see
that's what I feel like most people have
been like oh really so that's why I
think they were better off just not
doing
it cuz then you have to like pick which
position are they just going to be
another Seeker again maybe we have to go
to the
board
no
[Music]
am I supposed to talk to
you oh is it the notice board I didn't
see I didn't see wi and weld on
there is Wigan weld considered wit
sharpening oh you got to go through the
other
Pages oh my
[Music]
gosh
jeez I didn't know they had this many
potions that's
crazy so I guess for whatever the
easiest one that's when I'll need to to
do
uh wi and wild to get that trophy on
being being quick difficult mind if I
watch you make it good luck oh great
here we go all
right of course it's going to involve
[Music]
shaking all right chat we got to lock it
in Careo
we got to lock it
in oh I got to shake
again oh we shook it too much it it blew
up come on we can save this we can save
this we can save
this all right there we go come on turn
turn turn turn turn come on build up
that Time Force build up that
time dude I hate the shaking
man watch
out that's the mechanic I like the least
by far I think we've
lost oops not your best why don't you
have a
m Wigan World potion The Haunting music
when you have to shake like what yeah
what is that if I watch you make it
good luck it sounds like there's a Death
Eater approaching you or
something all right wait for the
bubbles ooh that was close man we almost
poured too
much oh great you
again all right and we want it to turn
kind of
that stir till it it's green that looks
good oh my gosh
why all right heat it
up all right much better start much
better
start dude just continuously having to
shake this
one I almost did that too
much spine of night
fish spine of lion fish
one
two not
three not three oh my
goodness why is it so hard to tell
exactly where it
is uh I believe so Mayo Wario would know
for sure if Wario is still here hanging
out come
on one
more
boom all right that looks like you and
of course we have to shake it up again
you guys weren't kidding man all
the the shaking definitely makes this
one more of a challenge especially since
that seems to be the uh the thing I
struggle with the
most all right Shake It Again shaking
again watch for the bubbles all right we
got
bubbles yeah Dylan now I see what you
mean about the black line I wonder if
that was
intended if they like put that in there
for people who were really so this one's
like yeah we're barely going to need to
add
any wow we finally have one that we
don't have have to shake let's
go yeah that makes a big
difference should be good right yep all
right now to
purple now to a light pink right
there floba mucus flaa
mucus no way all right and of course we
got to end it on one that we need to
shake
and we want to pour just barely man like
look at that black
line just
barely
nice very nice very
nice all right wig and weld potion
complete final score 3,260 hey we got
five stars on
it let's
go
oh so he's taking it now you have more
health and dueling now meet Dumbledore
in the astronomy
Tower yeah I think we I think we I think
we go forth and do it I think we go
forth and do
it have you seen Professor we've been
live for not even 3 hours not even 3
hours let's do this heading to the
astronomy Tower when I last saw them
then that'll actually line up perfectly
we we we'll finish this stream beating
the story and then the next stream will
be like finishing up
Collectibles going around 100% in the
game to to finish out the platinum
trophy at least that sounds like a plan
to me after I finish today and beat the
story I'll kind of put together a a game
plan for what we need
still to get the final trophies
all right Nick take me to dumble doll
bring back um it was
better I can't wait to see how they
handle this
part don't tell me don't tell me how
they do the cave scene I hope it's
better than the Lego
game the Lego games are really like the
Order of the Phoenix battle in the Lego
game is
fantastic but then when you get to the
uh the cave scene with Dumbledore the
Lego games they just like your you don't
get to do the coolest part you have to
stop the have you ever considered Fury
from attacking Dumbledore has it ever
crossed your brilliant mind that I don't
want to do this anymore I will not
negotiate this with your zus you
agreed has Dumbledore been like this the
whole game his mouth doesn't
move neighborhood Nova what's up bring
back brid oh my gosh a21 hey there
welcome
in all right my friend the time has come
to recover the hwrs the place we journey
to is exceedingly dangerous but I
promised you that you could accompany me
there is however a condition you
mustand you without question yes sir
understand what I'm saying should I tell
you to run hide or abandon me and save
yourself you will do so give me your
word Harry your word my word now are you
ready to embark on our dangerous little
Quest yes dude all right guys here it is
when you are ready to go talk to
Dumbledore Dumbledore I think I'm
ready how are we going to get there sir
apparation they spelled it
wrong they spelled it a
apparation this is the place Tom Riddle
stood here as a
boy he returned here many years later
with another
name
ominous not the name ominous
but now it is Lord Voldemort's obstacles
that stand in our way sir there are
bodies in the water oh what a we need
worry about but Harry do not touch the
water do you think the hwr is there oh
yes except the liquid must be drunk
remember the condition on which I
brought you with me whatever this potion
does to me you have to force it down my
throat his mouth's working now you gave
me your word Harry now your
health he can
talk
sir you you can't stop Professor you've
got to keep drinking don't don't make me
make it stop please make it stop it'll
stop but only if you
drink please one more just one more
Professor yeah they definitely sped that
up
water water definitely sped that
up that's okay that's a tough
scene oh man here we go dude here we go
here we
[Music]
go wait I'm in
control back you
Savages
dude they kind of look like the inury
from Hogwarts Legacy not going to lie
look at that look at
that I mean we do have a pretty good
description of what inferior supposed to
look like not a huge surprise there but
still kind of
[Music]
cool I I expect we're just going to get
overwhelmed at some
[Music]
point oh they're faster they're getting
faster
[Music]
I didn't know if it would work on them
that's
hilarious oh
goodness do you see the way that dude
was
crawling that was creepy
on all fours and he just started going
really fast kind of like
[Music]
jerking like that look at look look look
look oh that's so
weird oh no now we now is the the part
where we're going to get overwhelmed
no let's go Dumbledore let's
go wait where' they
go did we actually lose or
something I don't know what just
happened
[Music]
there
no oh he's not like he's not strong
enough yet we got to give him more time
you guys
[Music]
guys no back
up yeah I think it I think it's just I
think stupy is the best move here oh my
goodness for a second I thought that was
supposed to happen I thought we were
supposed to get
overwhelmed there we
go all right all right all right now we
got them under
control Harry I'm glad you know
stupified
oh no that one
was really
resisting come
on oh we get back to H
yes let's go
Dumbledore oh there he is man let's go
and that's it no why do they not want to
let you play as Dumbledore
man free
easy let me play this
Dumbledore and let me take the fire and
just come
on we need to get each to the hospital I
can't believe they don't want you to do
that okay there we
go like why man why would you not it is
Professor Snape I need why would you not
let us do that part Qui Harry hide
yourself below do not show yourself no
matter what Professor do as I say
Harry you are not an assassin Draco how
would you know I've done things that
would shock you like cursing Katy Bell
there are Death Eaters here IED the
vanish cabinet in the room of
requirement to let them in you didn't
see that coming did you spoilers
guys well done Draco a very key moment
right there killing is not nearly as
easy what just happened now look what we
have here double door wless and alone do
Draco he doesn't have the stomach the
dark lord was clear the boys to do it no
seus
please
aadab dang they sped it up in the game
seus please
of just straight straight into the AK
man out of here
quickly it's over time to
go
like they had the right scam but the
pacing was just so off the pacing was
way off they just needed to let it hang
for a little bit it's like they were
trying to rush
it they're like okay we got to get to
the end of the game actually that's how
the whole game has been like when it
comes to cut scenes and
story oh come on
come on don't get up close to me like
that snapes voice hey from the attic
what's up dude yeah SN snap's voice is
uh oh what what
what it's not alen Rickman that's for
sure nice that should do
it oh come
[Music]
on there we
go no way L1 I haven't seen the the live
action one but yeah it's just
like I don't know if they just didn't
want the game to feel cinematic or if
it's
just stup I don't know it's so so
bizarre it's like they had the
scene the lines weren't delivered great
but and they did have the M they had
some like good music to go at that
moment too but they just oh
man they just cut away from it so
quickly come on Harry get up
dude
Dodge there we go no not Pego finish
this
guy what's he got three
left come on
[Music]
Harry Nice that should do
it you guys hear this you guys hearing
this
you trying to talk trying to talk to
them Luna go ahead they know they know
you they definitely know
you she seriously wants out
again Sebastian would body the Death
Eaters now the last time we fought old
finer here this man was not a great
duelist let's see if he's gotten
any oh he's actually he's actually
trying to do something a little
different
now all right you went
[Music]
out now you do foro
yeah dude finer man not the best dualist
in the
world too busy uh being a
werewolf I'm surprised they like how
cool would that have been if you had to
fight him in he came after you and
werewolf
form there we go
[Music]
super leave him Potter belongs to the
dark lord leave
him he belongs to the Dark
Lord he trusted
you fight
back what they didn't they're not going
to
jumo De they're not going to have that
part
[Music]
oh come on I expected more from
Bell she's just like standing
[Music]
there
there we
go yeah so I've heard a21 so I've heard
supero go he didn't even try sectum
simpa sectum there it is you dare use my
own spells against me
Potter yet I'm the Half Blood
Prince
he's gone
later he's just out of there hagd Hagrid
you're all right Harry don't you worry
there's nothing dumbledor won't be able
to put right Hagrid Dumbledore what's
this with the dog Mark who's been killed
where's Dumbledore Harry where's
Dumbledore
um
Hagrid well we could arrange for the
Hogwarts Express to come
tomorrow what about Dumbledore's funeral
you shouldn't send the students home
they'll want to say to
say
[Music]
goodbye honestly it's a moment that we
all probably saw coming from the first
time from the first book you know you
know there's going to be a point when it
happens Snape it was always
Snape and I did nothing strange thinking
this is a piece of Voldemort Soul yeah
only it's not it's a fake there was a
note inside someone stole a real now I
have to find James Bond I have to finish
what thank for subscribing dude welcome
we have to finish it you don't honestly
think you can find all those h cruxes on
your own do you think we'll ever come
back to Hogwarts I don't know but there
are four more H cruxes out there and I'm
going to destroy them all and if I meet
sever Snape along the way well it'll be
all the worse for
him oh man there we go Adventure
completed press X to
continue and then it should take us
right back in dude how did they go from
this to Deathly Hallows man
like cuz this one was such a step in the
right direction
man deadly hallow should have been great
it should have been
incredible but I've heard that it's not
I've heard that it's not all right guys
so there we go we are in hold on let me
just grab this right
here so we are in the kind of uh I guess
like endless day now after you beat the
main game and we have 93 out of 150
crests so I'm
thinking maybe we can get it all in the
next stream I try to go about three
three three three and a half hours or
so um and it's probably going to be next
Tuesday like another Tri wizard
Tuesday try wizard Tuesdays that's what
I'm going to start calling
them that's right M store it is indeed
time to get the
Platinum you're from India welcome in
you've been watching since the launch of
Hogwarts Legacy let's go appreciate you
for all the support thank
you deathly hous was call a Potter I
know
right yeah there wasn't as much Hogwarts
like that's for sure they had they
couldn't do that Wario but still it's
like you I wish they had seen that as an
opportunity for so many more things they
could have
done but I'm not going to speak on it
too much until I actually play it myself
because hey maybe every maybe I'll think
everybody was wrong that it was actually
a great game
I don't think so but I had my
expectations set
dude what are you
looking he's
like wait what she doing the same
thing what is going on with these
people what is
happening okay yeah you h no you're good
you're good okay all right dude
all right um but yeah I had my
expectations set pretty low for this
game and ended up enjoying it I mean
it's it's in my it's in my top two I
don't know if it takes my spot above
chamber yet my my current favorite Harry
Potter game not counting Hogwarts Legacy
because I apparently have to say that
every time not counting Hogwarts Legacy
my favorite Potter game is uh Chamber of
Secrets on the GameCube like the PS2
GameCube
one but this one's number two right now
this one is number two may maybe even
able to overtake overtake the top spot
after I give it more thought but we
still got to go around we got to collect
everything so I think that's what we're
going to wrap up for today's stream and
then um just just keep track of the
channel you can follow me on Twitter in
the Discord whenever I decide to do it I
don't think it'll be this week I have a
lot of stuff to do this week I'm trying
to do at least one stream per week so um
right now if I had to put a tentative
guess on it it would be next next
Tuesday kind of same time and try to see
how much we can we can wrap up there but
guys thank you all so much for the
support man chat has been great all the
new members we had a bunch of new gifted
members new Subs uh super chats along
the way as well really appreciate all
the support man and to anybody on the
replay Squad sorry you have to deal with
the um there's probably going to be some
oddness with the music maybe it even
cutting out completely at some point but
if you made it all the way to the end
here don't forget that little uh oh wait
we did the broom we said the broom Emoji
didn't we how about you do three if you
made it to the very end you do three
broom emojis three broom emojis in the
comments letting us know you made it all
the way to the end guys before you head
out make sure you hit that thumbs up
button on the video before you go that's
going to help more people find it and we
also posted a new video uh yesterday on
the latest news regarding the Harry
Potter TV show so we have some news now
on the four possible
Riders but the biggest piece of
information for me from this report is
that apparently Max is open to the idea
of doing more than just a Harry Potter
reboot so nothing concrete it's very
early stages from what they were saying
but I know a lot of people were like uh
I don't really want to retelling of the
seven books again some people do some
people don't but it seems like they're
just like Wizarding World what do people
want what can we do so it seems like
there's definitely an openness to doing
more than
just the retelling so maybe at some
point we'll get we'll get the spin-offs
maybe at some
point Cheyenne thank you so much glad
you had a good time mad skip man thank
you for being here Arvin Warrior
Metatron lonus Christian gamer Dylan of
course eln Jenny thank you guys all for
being here mods big thanks to the mods
guys always helping us keep things under
control here which most of the time you
guys chat's pretty cool most of the time
you guys are cool in the chat don't
caused too many issues neighborhood Nova
yeah the Lego ones are really good the
Lego ones are are very solid jumping
toad stool thank you for being
here um oh man I don't know how to
pronounce this Peri Peri py r y sorry if
that is mispronounced but thank you very
much for being here hanging out as well
M stor thank you for being here
potterhead of course a21 thank you for
being here SE wolf pack
yo SE wolf pack thank you for being
here all right guys Yahoo as well thank
you for being here man as always thank
you all so much for watching guys and I
will talk to you again
soon